heõs is a huge place and if you're not  in your car or on a chocobo you'll  probably be running and unfortunately it  doesn't take too long for noctus to run  out of steam luckily there's a little  trick to never stop running  first press Start and go to the options  menu from there go to stamina and set it  for on  now little green meter should show up on  top of Noctis that says ST click the  sprint button and once it's about to run  out click it again  knock this will flash green and - a  little and voila your stamina bar is  full and as long as you time it right  you can keep chaining these together  until you've made it to your destination  final fantasy 15 is finally out we'll  have plenty more tips guides and  features to come so stay tuned to game  spot